let me ask you something where do you
want to be honestly I mean in life where
do you aspire to be what milestone do
you intend on reaching financially
romantically independently now envision
that future what does it look like is it
for the family-orientated I'm here at my
local golf club with my baby girl teach
you to swim health orientated or purely
profit driven listen if you could escape
your life right now
where would you go Uganda mmm-maybe
events no Paris perhaps you envision
somewhere more tropical simply living a
life of fun whatever you see hold on to
that address this one this need for a
second and ask yourself what do I need
to do to get in that building just build
it my hair I used to come here when I
was 16 years old I used to clean snooker
tables it's so crazy this was called
Reilly's before I used to clean snooker
tables here when I was 16 years old just
cuz I was hustling I was doing anything
just to get some extra money
I was plastering I was working for my
dad can you play something I can clean
snooker tables real well I remember
Ricky I remember when I used to work
here and I used to think because
obviously you know it's not it's not
great job that clean snooker tables it's
not a great building at the time I was
just pleased to get some money
but I remember I used to think man
imagining work in this building that
would be amazing that was like the dream
you know some of the things that were
the dream fast forward 12 years I mean
when I was six years old working and
sneaking snooker tables I was not very
popular I didn't really have any friends
and now I mean I was single now I've got
not only a beautiful family beautiful
kids
great friends you know mates and friends
I could buy this building I could buy
this building and this building and I
wouldn't even man I wouldn't even notice
I wouldn't even hardly notice the dent
in my bank and I know that sounds like a
jerkish thing to say but it's just it's
just mind-blowing what can change in
twelve years people I mean people people
underestimate what can happen in twelve
months because I think a lot can have a
lot having for you in 12 months yeah
people say you know they're like sixteen
in there saying oh when I'm 65 I want to
be financially secure or what I retire
at 45 listen man you can have it all and
you can what do you think if you just
think medium term or long term and I'm
talking in long term I'm a 28 year old
I'm pinching myself even so I was
walking around here know we've been
looking I've been pointing out yeah
driving around yeah it's crazy it's a
nice inspiron seen you go we're walking
for any life so this one grew up this
ways to live but I am this apartment
here I've got this papa daily sorry it's
just my blonde man but I think I never
thought that would happen I never
thought I'd be able to you know I mean I
in houses and apartments all over the
place around here and I just think but
also remember where you came from like
when you and no one's self made you know
I'm here because I've been helped I've
been trained I've been mentored I've had
people that have helped me put
properties when I was dealing to get a
mortgage my first property my step
they'd put it in his name for me he was
like a guarantor
you've been helped no no one self-made
and I think no matter how wealthy you
become now I'm wealthy I'd literally
could buy these buildings and honestly
it wouldn't yeah but but the thing is
remember where you came from remain
humble and these good smells just take a
walk around I think you know you're old
you're old towns I don't have to come
here but and what you can achieve
I mean those people people even when
they're 60 that I'm 60 years old or too
old man if you're 60 years old you got
he's still got good 10 20 years left of
of energy and strength you can change
the world when you're 60 years old and
what you might lack in in the same kind
of energy that our 20 year old retired
you make up in Excel
you're 16 years old you couldn't just
the time is now the time is now
excuse Kellerman Ricky's killing it
definitely I think anyone watching this
is thinking you know I want to do well
in probably weather listen get first
we'll get educated yeah and second of
all surround yourself with positive
like-minded people in average of the
five people spend most farmers which is
why our to spend my time with people
like Samuel because I want to be just as
successful as them I want to be like
them I want to I want to have what they
have and you know people like that
inspire me yeah and you know I could
walk around now like a Chuck on this
video I could point out to all my houses
the different properties how much
they're making but I don't want this to
be about me right now I want this to me
about you so just just just think
massive you know whatever you doing
right now if you clean the snooker
tables whatever you do and it's not
where you are right now is not bad but
if you know that you've got potential
for way more just dream big and go make
it happen
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]